and you can see by the way these
questions differentiate blah and hints
to something else they tend to be the
kinds of questions with they don't match
what you're being asked again doesn't
matter the nice memorized form that you
already have something we don't have a
shortcut for okay
and sure enough log X 1x squared so
therefore let's follow their clue
there's different shape login so correct
okay so question rule yes so what am I
gonna do
um vu - to start with so that's going to
be X that's me and you - is whatever X
okay vu - - u v - so use just the
numerator right and V - would just be 1
so completeness okay all over Facebook
okay now the denominators looking good
because that's sort of what we're going
to be expecting the numerator not so
much right because what we've got over
here is exercise whatever X is 1 minus
log X all right good okay so now it's
not that's not quite as obvious as
before where I had two things and like
he's the one I want so I'll just
integrate it so what I am gonna have to
do is break it up right I've got the log
x over x squared that's the part at 1
and then I'm gonna have 1 over x squared
here okay so this guy 1 over x squared
is here and this is what I want to
integrate so I'm gonna I'm gonna move it
over I'm actually going to swap these
two around okay because I want it to be
positive yes okay so now I can integrate
it's really everything with respect to X
so this will become what I'm after
there's the subject already now when you
integrate whatever x squared that's X to
the minus 2 right so reverse chain rule
you usually when we differentiate the
power goes down so this time since we're
integrating the power goes up so X to
the minus 2 turns into X minus 1 okay
good and then you can't just leave it
like that there's something else we have
to do when you differentiate you
multiply by the power right so this time
we should divide by the power which in
this case turns out to be the same thing
okay so dividing by minus 1 gives me a
negative on the front okay when you
integrate this guy you just get log X 1
X ok plus my constant don't forget you
alright so I'm almost done
now I just need to tidy up that's 4
minus 1 over X they have assented
nominator already actually so minus 1
minus log X okay so it didn't end up
being that much worse the trick was
though that what you get is in straight
away what you're after
okay so you got to do a little bit of
manipulation okay